- Unless you have no eyebrows at all,
or it's like a unibrow,
that's the only time I notice eyebrows.
- We're straight guys here
to review hot guys' eyebrows.
(upbeat music)
- Slater, yes! He's got great eyebrows.
- He's got great everything, man.
- This man puts more
effort into his eyebrows
than I put any into anything in my life.
- He's got that Latin flair,
you know that fullness to them.
- I've got to give it to him,
(bell ringing) hot eyebrows.
Eyebrows on fleek.
- I think this is a
very handsome gentleman,
but his eyebrows don't do it for me.
- I would say this guy needs more eyebrow.
- Yeah, me too.
I would like to see this
guy with more eyebrow.
- Let's just call a spade a spade.
These are bad eyebrows.
(Buzzer)
- It has nothing to do with
the thickness, it's the shape.
It goes out and it goes (popping noise).
- Dang!
- This guy is a hottie man.
- He is so hot and he's got an accent.
- Oh, bushy, these are bushy.
- You know, I'd say these
are actually pretty sexy.
(Bell dinging)
These are sexy brows.
- Now this is a guy where
the first thing you notice:
- Eyebrows, yeah.
- I like those.
- I do too.
- His eyebrows don't have great
density, but amazing color.
- This guy, I think, is perfect.
- They're strong, they're pretty even.
(Bell dinging)
Yeah, I mean those are
attractive eyebrows and I want
to be friends with them.
- Hey, there they are!
The greatest eyebrows in the game.
- Dude, its like two .45's
strapped to the front
of his face.
(Shooting sounds)
- If you're in a bar fight,
they're the eyebrows
you want on your side.
- World-class, (bell
dinging) probably the best
eyebrows on anyone.
- This guy.
- Unibrow.
- He is legendary for this thing.
He tried to patent or to
trademark the unibrow.
- It's so symmetrical. I'm
tempted to say on fleek.
- It's almost like he has a
third eyebrow between his brow.
- I saw him in an interview of him saying
"I'm never shaving the brow"
He likes it. He's like this is
my trademark and it's smart,
his nickname is The Brow.
- That's almost like a
woman with three breasts;
it's hot in concept,
(buzzer) but if you were
to actually see it, I
think you'd be horrified.
- I can't. I should say it's not hot,
but (dinging) I'm attracted to it.
- He played the vampire in the movies,
right, not the werewolf?
But he looks like he
played the werewolf here.
Everything's kind of like it looks
like he just changed back
from being a werewolf.
- I would fall in love
eternally with these eyebrows.
Twilight reference.
- This guy would have
lost out on a lot of roles
if it weren't for those eyebrows. Really.
(Magical sound)
- Can you imagine-- whoa,
that was horrifying.
- I just put my finger over the eyebrows.
- Robert Pattinson (bell
dinging), beautiful eyebrows.
- Robert Pattinson's
nothing without his brows,
you heard it here first.
- Nothing. Those eyebrows are MVP.
(laughing)